you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
can big oil make big changes bp's chief
executive
tells sky news the company can help the
world go green
why we'll all be using much more
electricity in the future
as countries race to reach net zero
and the man working to bring renewable
energy to africa
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come well coming up how scientists in
australia are trying to save
the platypus at risk of extinction
because of extreme weather events
but first let me take you over to our
data dashboard and i can show you here
just how much our planet has warmed
since the industrial revolution it's
this figure
here now in 2015 countries agreed to try
and keep that number
below 2 degrees preferably to 1.5
degrees of warming
now doing that will mean big changes
from big oil and gas companies
such as bp well our business presenter
ian king has been speaking to their
chief executive and we'll hear from him
in a moment
but first let's take a look at what the
oil giant is doing to address their role
in the climate crisis so bp has pledged
to become a net zero company
by 2050. now their aim is to include
a 50 cut in the carbon intensity of
products it sells but not actually to
stop
the production of fossil fuels now it
plans to reach net zero by selling
25 billion dollars of assets in the next
four years
which will fund renewable investments
and that includes projects like two
offshore wind farms in the irish sea bp
and its partners paid 924 million pounds
for the license to build them but oil
isn't out of the picture for bp this
time last year the covert 19 pandemic
had a catastrophic
impact on the global oil and gas
industry
and you can see here how low prices
plummeted from around 70
per barrel to as low as 20 but it is
making a comeback and that's something
bp's chief executive ben looney
thinks will continue he told sky news he
can see a continued demand for oil
with prices staying at around their
current levels
there is uncertainty on the demand
outlook but it is very strong
in america it's very strong in china and
of course we've got the stabilizing
influence of opec who has both the
capacity and the desire
it seems to hold the market in that sort
of 60 to 70 dollar world so
lots of uncertainty as usual the
stabilizing influence of opec in the
background
we feel quite good about the outlook for
price
well bernalillo was speaking to our
business presenter ian king who joins me
now
so ian bp have pledged to become net
zero by 2050
but does that mean it's cutting back on
its oil production well yes it genuinely
is
anna i mean the main commitment that bp
have made is that by 2030 they'll have
cut their
oil and gas production by 40 that was
from february last year
now last year alone their production
fell by around 10
it's fallen again in the most recent
quarter on an underlying basis around 14
and bernard looney expects it to
continue falling in the current quarter
as well that's partly due to maintenance
and outages associated with that and
also due to those asset disposals that
you
mentioned but they are genuinely
reducing their oil and gas production
and indeed
in june last year bernard looney
actually went on record as saying that
some of the assets that they have would
actually remain in the ground
in other words exploration acreage that
they bought
they will no no longer be producing so
they are putting their money where their
mouth is
to that extent but it's worth bearing in
mind that this year they'll invest
something like 13 billion us dollars
altogether
nine billion of that will be in their
conventional fossil fuel activities with
the remainder going on
renewables well i asked bernard looney
earlier about cop 26 in particular
and how enthusiastic he was about
progress being made
green companies low carbon zero carbon
companies are fantastic
but regardless of the growth rates
they're not going to solve the world's
problems what the world needs
is greening companies and by greening i
mean companies like bp who are carbon
intensive today but who have net
zero ambitions mark carney says if you
want to solve climate
go to where the emissions are well the
emissions are here we're transitioning
how do we encourage and support greening
companies
now companies like bp are often accused
of green wash of uh
making promises that they can't keep but
what's really interesting i think is
that bp
have over the last 12 months got a
considerable amount of buy-in from the
likes of greenpeace and friends of the
earth
who do seem genuinely convinced that
they are sincere in their approach
the bigger question perhaps is investors
a lot of investors here in the city are
yet to be convinced
that bp is going to in future make the
same returns on a financial basis
from renewables that it does from its
conventional fossil fuel activities
ian thank you now let me take you back
to our data dashboard
and in order to keep this number here as
close to 1.5 degrees as possible
the world is going to have to move
towards using clean energy
now that means a much bigger reliance on
electricity which can be produced and
consumed
in a renewable way rather than other
energy sources like natural gas
which can't be well a new report from
the energy transitions commission says
there'll have to be a massive
mobilization of resources
to move from fossil fuel generated power
to clean electricity
so how are we doing in great britain
today well as you can see 50
of our electricity today is coming from
fossil fuels we've got 34
coming from renewable sources and 16
there from nuclear
well that ambition to make everything
electric is going to have a huge
impact on the global supply of
electricity now in 2020
around 27 000 terawatt hours
of electricity was supplied worldwide
and 10
of that was generated by wind and solar
power
the rest is primarily fossil fuels but
the demands by 2050 are going to be
almost
five times as much with around 130
000 terawatt hours needed
now to reach net zero between 75 and 90
will have to be wind and solar and the
rest zero carbon
so let's take a look at three of the
biggest growth sectors for electricity
and you can see that electric road
transport goes up
to seven seventeen thousand terawatt
hours
heating buildings with electricity will
take up 22 000 terawatt hours
and electric base advances in shipping
and aviation
could use up to 12 000 terawatt hours
just those three together is more than
the entire
global electricity demand of last year
well faustine de la salle is the
director of the energy transitions
commission which produced
the report with those findings fasting
de la salle
if countries around the world are going
to achieve net zero just how
important is the electrification of many
aspects of our lives
clean electricity is really going to be
the foundation
upon which we can develop the whole
energy transition and
we're figuring out that uh electricity
will probably represent 70 percent
of our final energy consumption uh by
mid-century
and that means as you've just shown as a
number
a major massive investment required
in the production of electricity because
we need to do two things at the same
time
we need to uh decrease the carbon
intensity of our current
power production and you've shown the uk
numbers today they're better than they
would have been
10 years ago but they're still not good
enough
um but we also need to grow that
electricity electricity system
very significantly well yes it sounds
like a huge
challenge and obviously the ambition is
to make sure the electricity
is powered by renewable sources and not
fossil fuels so how would you describe
that challenge
i think the main challenge here is
really to leverage
private finance there is money in the
world
that can invest in those uh renewable
energies
and renewable energies today are
becoming cheaper than fossil fuels
production so it makes business sense
to invest in renewable energy but we
need
a design of the market that actually
enables people to make money out of it
and that's what we call power market
design it's on governments to ensure
that um investors can make money by
investing in renewable energy
and what do governments need to do
it's quite simple it's about how you
manage
your electricity market and it's about
doing what we've done successfully
in germany in the uk uh for several
years now
um which is auctions uh giving people
the certainty that they will have
um a revenue for renewable energy over
long periods of time
that enables them to invest safely
with a certainty of revenue fasting de
la salle thank you very much indeed
in today's other climate news the
national trust is restoring a wetland in
cornwall to help attract new wildlife
and reduce flooding the original flood
plain a coat hill was converted into
four acres of farmland by the victorians
nearly 200 years ago the charity says
turning it back to wetland
will help store carbon in the mud and
trap sediment to clean the river
australian scientists are on a mission
to save the platypus from extinction
the team from the university of new
south wales have been tracking down and
tagging the animals
to monitor their population platypus
numbers have dropped by as much as 30
percent in the last 30 years
as their habitats have been destroyed by
flooding and wildfires
[Applause]
and maisie williams has become the first
global climate ambassador for wwf
the actor best known for her role in
game of thrones will support the
charity's mission to turn the climate
crisis around
by 2030. she says if we all make small
changes we could create a meaningful
impact
now for the latest in our series of
climate diaries and today we're hearing
from tony tu
who's on a mission to get africa to
embrace renewable energy
more than half of sub-saharan africans
don't have access to reliable
electricity
but tony's working on a green solution
hello or like we say in my language is
lay
i am turnitive the founder and the ceo
of renewables in africa
i used to be part of an engineering
organization in the uk
where i saw this very famous satellite
image
showing the distribution of power across
the globe
and i was literally in shock in cm why
up until that moment i never realized
how
serious the power situation was in my
beloved continent
africa i grew up in cameroon i used to
be in the dark with few lights
and it's up until you get confronted
right with a different
set of reality that you start to
understand
the challenge you are facing this
picture changed my whole career
and my whole life our goal is to educate
people and raise their technical
awareness of renewables energy
a second mandate is to be an engineering
company so we bring
clean energy solutions to businesses we
may not be
one of the biggest polluters in the
planet we nevertheless
within the brunt of climate change my
mission is simple
is to bring back power to africa
and our vision is to turn the dark
continent that i saw in 2008
into a brighter and prosperous one by
2014.
that's everything from us for today
tomorrow we'll be speaking to former f1
world champion nico rosberg about
extreme e
the racing series raising awareness of
climate change
and you can catch that on the daily
climate show here on sky news and
our social channels see you then thanks
for watching
you